[Music]
are you losing your mind at just my tick
tock is now just me guessing paint
colors it's just because this is the
little okay a little yellow a little
white
a handful of blue and a lot of red so
that would be the blue and the others be
like a dark green a dark green
and a lot of red with a hint of white so
a light green with a hint
would it be mauve would this make like a
a dark
like it would be this it'd be like a
dark mauve color
oh uh
oh i don't know now i'm really uh it's
gotta be mud i'm just gonna lighten it
i'm just gonna go with a lighter move
oh did it go into white paint or did it
go into a gelatin no i'm changing my
mind
confident this went into white paint so
it should be a much lighter mouth
oh god come on give me this wing give me
this wing give me this
here we go i thought i was really good
at this but my it's just
i think oh tiny bitty yellow oh a tiny
green
yellow and green like what oh it's gonna
be like a
a dark look there's black oh
oh oh i have a thing and i reckon it's
got to be this
doesn't it why does this color just make
my skin look
awful a bit sunburnt i think
come on i need this for the win i need
this win
[Music]
all right let's try this again green
blue
brown green blue brown
a green and a blue and a brown okay
a lot more blue and brown
now a lot more oh i don't bloody
know what
i've been wrong so many times maybe
like maybe this because like
i don't know but every time like it
comes out it just
hasn't made any sense do i stick with
this
i really want to stick with this but
then like the like
gambling part in me is like oh no take a
risk
take a risk i couldn't i couldn't take
the risk
thanks jesus i'm gonna say good with
that one yet
i just can't stop i can't stop
this is just such an addictive game okay
black
white black white makes gray so grey
yellow and mustard so it's a yellow
so it's a yellow with a
oh you reckon
pastel yellow it's got to be some sort
of pasteli
because grey i would like
[Music]
says the expert i got no all the
hairdressers are like oh i'm a pro at
this i have to color so much hair and
they nail it every time
pisses me off come on oh this dress
please please i'll take your time
we're back playing my favorite game
what's that color gonna
look like red black
and white red black and white
oh this is just gonna be
like a oh this will be a nice like
flamingo pink i reckon
just a dark flint oh no what's the point
of adding black if you're adding so much
white
oh this is going to be like a hot pink
i bet 100 that
well maybe it's gonna be a bit more it's
gonna be a bit more pastely
the thing that's throwing me is they
added black why would you need to add
black if you're adding so much white
what does that do
does it make it more matte finish oh god
here we go
i love this sermon oh my god
[Music]
you